[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur l'ancienne Philadelphie romaine dont
il subsiste les restes d'un théâtre
antique Amman a pris son essor qu'avec
la création du royaume de Jordanie il
n'y a pas si longtemps de cela puisque
cette nation n'a quitte en 1946 alors la
ville ne comptait que 35 000 habitants
aujourd'hui Aman ne compte pas loin de
500 000 habitants le quart de la
population d'un pays de 80000 km² où le
désert domine
cette capitale qui a gardé malgré son
développement rapide l'aspect d'un gros
bourg traduit une volonté de
modernisation sans tapage dans son
palais d'Ammann le roi Hussein ne nous a
pas dit autre chose nous sommes
peut-être un petit pays mais notre seul
but est d'améliorer les conditions de
vie de notre peuple a-t-il expliqué
avant d'adresser un salut à la France je
voudrais bien envoyer à travers
actualités français mais amitié très
cordial à la grande nation française
il reste que la géographie dispose et
les soucis du roi Hussein suivent le
tracé des frontières jordaniennes la
frontière avait Israël fait de la
Jordanie la gardienne d'une partie des
lieux saints ce sans doute qui sont le
plus cher au monde chrétien le monde des
oliviers ou depuis deux millénaires vit
toujours le souvenir de la méditation du
Christ
[Applaudissements]
et puis la vieille Jérusalem celle où
chaque année des milliers de pèlerins
viennent refaire de ruelles en ruelle de
marche en marche le chemin que suivi
Jésus portant sa croix
c'est aussi dans la Jérusalem
jordanienne que s’élève la mosquée
d'Omar à la place même ou avait été bâti
le temple du roi Salomon
et aussi que s’élève le mur des
lamentations pèlerinage déserté par les
juifs depuis 1948 date de l'armistice
avec Israël car depuis cette époque un
mur a un franchissable coupe la ville
sainte mur un franchissable aux
israéliens dans lequel pourtant reste
ouvert le seul passage entre l'État
d'Israël et le monde arabe encore ne
franchitons cette porte que dans un sens
exception faite des voitures des Nations
Unies et le no man's land est là pour
rappeler que l'armistice n'est pas la
paix
[Musique]
depuis 1948 la célèbre légion arabe n'a
pas cessé de poursuivre un entraînement
intensif
[Musique]
ces soldats rude sont maintenant les
plus sûrs garants du trône et les 40 000
bédouins du désert qui composent cette
armée acquis pour la parade au
cornemuses écossaises explique ce qu'on
a appelé le miracle jordanien entre
Israël cerné par le Moyen-Orient arabe
et les Etats frères bouleversés par le
bouillonnement révolutionnaire la
Jordanie tient en effet une sorte
d'équilibre difficile et tenue et cet
équilibre repose sur la Légion arabe
[Musique]
le professeur Calmette aurait 100 ans
aujourd'hui c'est lui qui avec Guérin
donna à l'humanité cette arme préventive
tant attendue contre la tuberculose le
BCG on devrait maintenant être à l'abri
du Fléau et pourtant
êtes-vous vacciné contre la tuberculose
les faits sont éloquents faute de
vaccination des individus et des
individus jeunes sont atteints au point
qu'aux pays de Calmette la tuberculose
tue 6 fois plus qu'au Danemark ou le BCG
généralisé depuis longtemps
dans les villes surtout le refus de
certains malades adultes d'aller dans
sanatorium a même accru les risques de
contamination tuberculose auxquelles les
enfants sont particulièrement exposés il
importe d'assurer à ces derniers sans
exception la protection du BCG une
simple formalité en vérité mais cet acte
banal pratiqué dès le plus jeune âge
préservent les enfants d'affection
graves comme la méningite tuberculeux
aucun incident sérieux ne risque de
résulter de cette méthode en effet les
millions de vaccinations réalisées dans
le monde à tous les âges se sont révélés
d'une extrême efficacité
99% de succès on en contrôle du reste
aisément le résultat par la culture
réaction qui renouvelait d'année en
année permet de s'assurer que le sujet
est toujours protégé
[Applaudissements]
en 1963 on ne devrait plus pouvoir se
priver de cette assurance sur l'avenir
le BCG
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ancien président du Conseil député de la
Moselle de 1919 à 1962 Robert Schuman
est mort la présence de cinq anciens
chefs de gouvernement dans le très long
cortège qui à Metz l'a accompagné à son
dernier voyage celle de Monsieur Louis
Jobs représentant le gouvernement celle
de nombreuses délégations françaises et
étrangères ont souligné la personnalité
de celui qui vient de disparaître et
dont la signature en 1951 fenêtre le
pool charbon acier première base de cet
édifice européen qu'il avait voulu de
toutes ses forces et auquel leur a né au
Luxembourg il n'avait jamais cessé de
travailler
le démembrement de l'Europe est une
cause permanente et croissante de
faiblesse dans tous les domaines
politiques économiques militaire
la mise en commun organique de nos
ressources seraient au contraire une
garantie de prospérité de puissance et
de paix
en 1953 commençait à couler le premier
acier qu'on pouvait bien nommer européen
puisqu'il n'existait plus pour lui de
frontières depuis l'unité de l'Europe a
fait son chemin la disparition des
barrières douanières est en route dans
le cadre du marché commun qui s'est
ajouté avec leur atome aux poules
charbon acier pour constituer un marché
de plus de 160 millions d'Européens
en 1958 Robert Schuman recevait à
Aix-la-Chapelle le prix Charlemagne qui
apportait une juste consécration à
l'oeuvre à laquelle il s'était voué avec
cet homme simple c'est en effet un grand
Européen qui s'en va l'un des pères
véritablement de l'Europe
[Musique]
son papa lui avait demandé de reprendre
les titres européens du sang et 200
mètres d'eau et Christine Caron est une
fille obéissante dans sa tentative
contre le record à la piscine Georges
Vallerey elle virait au 100m dans
l'excellent temps de une minute 13
secondes
dans la troisième longueur elle laissait
loin derrière elle les autres nageuses
et sans forcer se donnant même le luxe
de ralentir sa cadence elle touchait en
fin de course le mur en deux minutes 32
secondes un dixième battant ainsi de
deux dixièmes le record d'Europe tant
au-dessous de ses possibilités aussi son
entraîneur lui a-t-il promis une
médaille aux Jeux Olympiques de Tokyo
[Musique]
finale des championnats du monde de ski
nautique à Vichy dans le slalom féminin
américain Janet Brown remporte une
facilite victoire la française Dany
Duflot favorite mes blessés n'ayant plus
défendre ses chants
dans la France remportait une belle
victoire dans les figures
cette jeune fille de 15 ans pour son
entrée dans l'équipe nationale connaît
du même coup la consécration
ces championnats d'ailleurs se déroulent
sous le signe de la très nouvelle vague
l'Américain Spencer n'a pas plus de 14
ans l'année dernière champion des
juniors aujourd'hui champion du monde
des figures
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il se donnait même le luxe le lendemain
de remporter le titre du slalom sourire
aux lèvres lancé à 60 km à l'heure il
passait siboué et nous rater la dernière
que de quelques centimètres du très
grand art
un saut le Suisse clair qui avait fait
42 mètres 70 à l'entraînement tombait et
l'Américaine Jackson remportait
l'épreuve avec un impeccable vol plané
de 49
[Musique]
et dans le défilé final Spencer
aiguilleandal 29 ans à eux deux
symboliser la victoire des États-Unis et
de la France
[Musique]